Everyone good morning it's Mark Wiens
with migrationology.com
This is Day Two in Taipei and we are heading to breakfast
Breakfast is included in our hotel, so we're going for breakfast now,
and today is going to be a sightseeing day in Taipei.
Breakfast is located at
the other location of this hotel,
which is just a block away and it's a
breakfast buffet and it's actually
pretty impressive over here I got a
plate of vegetables with some kind of
pickles and then this is a plate there's
a little bit of noodles there and then I
think that's just stir fried onions in
tofu and then I got a bowl of dumplings
and vegetables
hmm Oh
lots of garlic and sesame oils we are
walking towards the longshan temple
which is one of the oldest and one of
the main landmarks in Taipei that's
where we're headed now okay
there's the sign up there to longshan
temple 700 meters
I can see the sign in the distance we
are approaching Guangzhou Street so
we're getting very close to the temple
we made it to longshan temple you can
see in the back of me back there the Sun
is blazing hot right now from what I
read it was built in 1738
originally by immigrants from the Fujian
province of China but now it has been
rebuilt a couple of times because it was
destroyed in various natural disasters
as well as in World War two but this
remains one of Taipei's most important
landmarks and buddhist temples
longshan temple was very amazing to
visit really busy today and full of
energy and now we're walking across the
street to the MRT station we're at the
MRT station now and gonna look into
buying the EZ card which is a card so
you can so we don't have to keep on
buying single journey tickets but we can
put money on that card and then be able
to take the metro easily I didn't see
this at first but it's a vending machine
to buy that easy card tickets is our
pleasure to serve you easy card purchase
ok successful the card cost 100 for
deposit and then we added 100 for ticket
fare this will be much more convenient
we are at the very front of the train
but it's so clean and so spacious the
MRT in Taipei is really nice we're
getting off the MRT at Chiang kai-shek's
nation
here's the map says for us to take exit
number five and then walk through the
park to the Memorial Hall
and one of the things that really
strikes me is just how massive it is so
in the photos you can't really judge how
big it is but in reality or when you're
here it's huge and there are from what I
read there are 88 steps to the first
platform of the Memorial Hall and I'm
going to go climb those now and see what
is up there this whole square is really
nice some really nice buildings and over
there behind me is the National Theatre
made it to the top of the staircase and
there is a great view behind me and
coming to the memorial now we just
happened to catch the tail end of that
ceremony but now we can walk in here and
see the memorial
the memorial is open from 9 a.m. to 6
p.m. and they have a changing of the
guard ceremony every hour we're back on
the street now but before we left the
hotel in the morning I looked up a place
to eat Taiwanese
soup dumplings which is not too far away
so we are walking there now and I hope
we can find this restaurant for lunch
I think that is the sign I think that's
the restaurant we're gonna eat right
there with that red sign
downstairs is where they are making all
of the dumplings and doing all the
cooking and then upstairs they have a
really nice dining room sitting in the
AC right now feels really good and about
to order some food heated and Suzanne
thank you
pork dumplings okay Shalom bow the soup
dumplings have arrived and you got to
eat these immediately as they are hot
and fresh these are just little beauties
you can almost feel a little bit of
juice swimming around in these little
pockets of wrappers put it into my bowl
and you have to be careful biting into
these you do not want a one bite these
because all that soup will come
squirting out and can really burn your
tongue in your mouth so you want to be
careful be nice
five sizes
okay they're not that hot probably
because I took so long taking photos of
them but that flavor is wonderful the
rapper is kind of gummy and then the
pork inside is really soft and tender
for my next fight I'm going to reach
over and grab that chili oh that is a
pretty oily but good-looking chili sauce
put some of that on to there and then
but they put the rest on into the bowl
for the for the next dumpling
yeah
along with soup dumplings this
restaurant is also famous for their
fried chicken at least everybody seems
to be ordering it so let me taste this
that is quite quite a deep-fried miss
around the edges of the chicken
that's crazy crispy on the edges Paul
and then that chicken is not overcooked
on the inside it's really juicy as well
well that's good and it's not over salty
either
now for the shrimp dumplings and you can
see they are a little different similar
shape but at the top they spread it out
instead of closing it and stuck a little
shrimp on the top but before I will dip
it quickly into this chilli sauce
and we also got a couple plates of
vegetables
oh that's very nice and crisp really
juicy and a little bit a little bit
salty and sweet
oh because they're very very garlicky
that's good we just finished with lunch
those were some excellent soup dumplings
I wish I would have wouldn't have taken
so many photos so I would have been able
to eat them when they were hotter and
fresher because they would have been
even better but still they were really
good we got to the main street and you
can see just in front of me that is the
famous Taipei 101 building we're not
going to go there today but maybe
sometime in the next few days for sure
so stay tuned for that it's about 5:30
in the late afternoon we are heading
towards the Shilin night market
we just got off the metro and we're
going to take exit one for shillin night
market just a quick travel tip I was
waiting until we could find a tourist
information center which is right there
right here at the exit of the Metro but
in Taiwan you can get a student kind of
a youth discount for many of the
attractions as well as some
transportation all you have to do is to
qualify as B from the age of 15 to 30
and so I barely barely qualify just for
a couple of more months I'm 29 years old
you fill out this really short
application just your name and your
birthdate basically and then they give
you this little pass and if you are 15
to 30 years old when you come to Taipei
you can do the same
we got here right at dusk and already
there are lots of people here and we're
walking down one of the lanes they're
just shops mostly closed shops right now
on both sides of the street and there we
passed a lot of food already and I know
there's going to be more food coming
soon but we're just going to leisurely
walk around for a while
there are so many people here tonight
and just packed it's single file but I
think this is a food lane at least it
looks like and so we're going to walk
down this lane
okay we're going to stop at this stall
first for some fish balls
we got the dark colored and they said it
is the spicy version
oh that is very spongy and I can date
some black pepper and a little bit of
chilli deep we just came to the end of
the market and we found a shop that is
selling I'm not I'm not sure what
they're called I will find out and write
it here but they are pieces of dough
which are filled with either meat or
something sweet and then cooked wrapped
into like a calzone and then just like
naan they are slapped on the edge of the
oven and cooked and all this is just
warm and all beautiful and then topped
with just a ton of sesame seeds and I
got that pork version
oh that's ridiculously good oh and
here's something funny
when I took a bite one of those sesame
seeds like blew out and flew into my
nose that bread is really crispy and
then inside the meat is a little bit
sweet and I can taste onions and
I mean wow that's delicious
I'm gonna
can you order me one young Oh
in demand gun okay I'm going to order
one of these tofu on skewers
all this yes please
thank you
spicy yes please I just ordered what I
think is kind of a tofu hot dog without
the hot dog so it's basically a two
strips of tofu which looked appeared to
be deep-fried and then I think there is
some cabbage and I'm not sure what else
inside of there and then stopped with
cilantro and she topped it with a little
bit of pepper or chili powder oh yeah oh
it's just one giant piece of tofu
wrapped into a u-shape and then drizzled
in dark sauce
oh that's very fluffy tofu and then the
outside has kind of a crunchy skin
around it I think this might be a
surprise piece of stinky tofu because it
does have a little bit of a but it's not
very strong
I was thinking though I had some stinky
tofu and when I was in mainland China a
couple years ago and it was much like
had a more pronounced flavor and smell
to it but this is not not very strong
maybe this is a mild stinky tofu but
it's very good
I'm still not sure if that was stinky
tofu or not but if it was I was totally
surprised I had no idea it was stinky
tofu and it was delicious
I can taste a little bit of a like kind
of rotting sewage fish taste
but that tastes pretty good and I love
that tofu it was a really good texture
really like spongy and kind of crumbly
it was a little bit sweet but that kind
of compromised with it being a little
bit spicy and then that cilantro touch
on top that was awesome we are still
walking around Sheol in night market
this market is incredibly huge and there
are so many shops and so many food
stalls that it's mind-blowing
even though I've only been in Taipei now
for two days something I've been
noticing a lot on the streets is little
cubes of snake which are grilled and
then blow-torched
finally I could not resist ordering one
and so yeah they're little cubes of
snake he he blowtorch them a couple of
different times and you could just see
the oils and fat just sizzling there
were a couple different ways you could
order it one which was just salt and one
was pepper but I got something called
singeing cumin which I have no idea how
you pronounce that but it's it's cumin
and I can oh I could just feel that
juiciness in that skewer
all that is extremely juicy it is it's
not quite buttery so it doesn't fall
apart in your mouth but it has some
texture to it I can't really taste the
cumin on that and then it's perfectly
salted on that note of finishing that
blowtorch steak we are heading back to
our hotel now it's been another long day
and I'm going to end the vlog here and I
just want to say thank you for watching
this vlog please remember to give it a
thumbs up leave a comment below and I
would love to hear from you and thank
you very much for watching and see you
on the next video